[Music]
hey everybody its charlie big news Matt
Reeves dropped all kinds of Batman movie
bombs yesterday at the TCAs he revealed
a whole bunch of details about the story
what Ben Affleck's involvement is how
it's connected to the DC Universe so we
got to break it down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the DC videos there's gonna be a
whole bunch of stuff happening in the
next couple of months and there's a new
brand of that blast ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video most important thing first when
are we actually gonna get this movie he
said this is me quoting him we're
working on getting our drafted in the
next couple of weeks right now my head
is totally into the script right now I'm
going to be leaving here and going back
to work on the script when he says leave
here he's talking about the tcas
there's a bunch of TV networks that are
doing a bunch of panels revealing what's
going on with television in general next
year Matt Reeves has a new TV series
that's unrelated to Batman stuff so
that's why he was at this panel
naturally wally was there everybody
asked him all these Batman movie
questions but here's the thing as for a
release date there's no official release
date but the word is is they might start
shooting earlier next year because he's
turning in this final draft now so
because it's a smaller Detective movie
it's a little bit easier to get it out
of post-production meaning it be about a
year turnaround so if they start
shooting early next year that means
maybe summer released 2020 but who knows
what part of the year they would drop it
in I mean it's a Batman movie typically
those just wind up being summer movies
when people asked him about Ben
Affleck's involvement and how it's
connected to the DC Universe this is his
direct quote there are ways in which all
this connects to DC to the DC Universe
as well he's talking about connecting
these to the other superheroes movies
like Justice League all the other
spin-off movies that we've been doing
connecting it to the larger DC Universe
even though this is gonna be a prequel
with a much younger version of Batman
and we're not gonna see Superman or a
bunch of other superheroes running
around in it it'll just be Batman and
Batman's rogues gallery of villains but
the suggestion was made because he said
that he's in contact with Ben Affleck on
a regular basis when people are like
as I flick an Aleve is he gonna be a
part of the movie so obviously he didn't
want to completely give that detail away
but the idea is is that the actor that
they're looking to play Batman in the
movie has to be in his 20s Ben Affleck
is playing a 40-plus version of Batman
so after moustache gate they're not
gonna spend millions and millions of
dollars try to make Ben Affleck fake
look younger they're gonna opt for
sanity and just cast a much younger
version of the character now people are
all wondering who that's going to be
I'll talk about that in a second but as
for actual Ben Affleck involvement
people are thinking that they'll include
scenes whereby Ben Affleck's Batman
flashes back remembering the events of
this movie and that's how you invoke his
character and tie it to the larger DC
Universe so you have the entire plot of
the movie beginning to end and then the
post-credits scene is Ben Affleck's
Batman remembering all this stuff as for
the story people had thought that he was
gonna be doing Frank Miller's a year one
he confirmed that that is not going to
be part of his movie at all all he said
was that I'm quoting him again he says
we're not doing any particular comic
year one was one of the many comics that
I loved we are definitely not doing year
one it's just exciting to be focused
very specifically on a tale that is
defying for him and very personal to him
talking about the Batman character
obviously we're not doing an origin tale
or anything like that we're doing a
story that is definitely Batman though
in trying to tell a story that's
emotional and yet is really about him
being the world's greatest detective and
all the things that for me when I was a
kid made me love Batman so a lot to
unpack in that comment he's talking
about doing a world's greatest detective
movie in most of the big Batman movies
we've gotten like through Nolan's
trilogy were big action films
yes
so when people talk about it as a neo
noir detective thriller a smaller Batman
movie that's what they're talking about
world's greatest detective which it
won't surprise you to hear the last time
that I heard somebody from DC talking
about Matt Reeves early ideas for the
movie is that it was being referred to
as mask of the phantasm but with Robin
so if you never saw a mask of the
phantasm one of the best Batman movies
of all time it just happens to be
animated it's basically Batman the
Animated Series doing a movie which is
very much a detective thriller story
about Batman earlier in his career about
a character that's very personal to him
a moment where he almost gave up being a
vigilante to marry another socialite
named Andrea Beaumont that he had fallen
in love with so this is very early in
his time as Batman but she mysteriously
leaves town with her father later the
phantasm villain character comes back
and starts killing off mobsters so he
has to do the detective route to find
out who this person is why they're going
after all the mobsters what their
motivation is he learns that it is the
Andrea Beaumont character that he had
fallen in love with years and years ago
when he was much much younger and she
was seeking revenge for the death of her
father so it's very personal to him but
he has to go through all these steps to
find out who it is you still following
your dad's orders way I see it the only
one in this room controlled by his
parents is you mark Hamill's Joker was
also a big part of that story but I
haven't heard anything about Joker
appearing in this Matt Reeves Batman
movie so they might swap him for the
penguin or another character penguin has
just been the one that people have been
talking about the most
so it'll feature classic Batman villains
but just imagine a fairy mask of the
phantasm type of story and if you
haven't seen that do please go watch
that movie because it's amazing but he
also says that they're not doing an
origin story meaning that we probably
won't redo the Crime Alley scene over
and over again think about the ways of
war and Spider Man homecoming handled
Uncle Ben when they redid Tom Hollands
spider-man I gotta know what your mo
would
get out of that twin bed in the morning
look when you can do the things that I
can but you don't
and then the bad things happen they
happen because you just a real quick
really effective emotional conversation
with Iron Man's character and they never
mentioned it again I think we'll all
probably be okay
if they don't do Crime Alley for the
billionth time almost every single new
Batman story has done Crime Alley and
it's just like okay we can trust people
to understand what happened to his
parents I know everybody's asking who is
this younger actor they're gonna get to
play the character so when I say younger
I'm talking like armie hammer younger
they're people that have been throwing
out suggestions for ansel elgort like
people that are really really young and
I don't think that they want to go that
young with Batman like it's not super
important that they get a name if they
get an unknown I'm totally fine with
that and if they want to do another
Justice League movie said in present day
or if they end up doing the war of light
with the Green Lantern Corps if that
ends up panning out and they want to
recast another version of Batman that's
older I'm totally fine with that the
beauty of this Batman prequel movie is
that it's set so far in the past that
you can justify casting a much younger
version of the character and then
recasting another older version if Ben
Affleck doesn't come back for movie set
in present day but hopefully it all
works out and ends up being amazing and
the younger actor will just continue on
in whatever future movies there are if
Ben Affleck doesn't come back but like I
said Matt Reeves said that he was in
contact with Ben Affleck I think his
involvement just depends on what the
final script looks like I think Affleck
is just waiting for Matt Reeves to
finish this recent draft to see whether
or not he enjoys the script and if he
thinks it's good he'll probably
participate in some way post all your
reactions in the comments below
and I'll name a new giveaway winner when
I post new DC there is a whole bunch of
Flash stuff happening so maybe a new
flash video in the next couple of days -
but click here to rewatch the Aquaman
trailer again and click here for all
those infinity ward's deleted scenes
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you